anyway I heard that there was another
Nico Santos as well right he's a singer
there's his Nico Santos from Germany oh
yes he's a singer that's not my
boyfriend never working but people on
social media always tagged me instead of
him and they're just like I love your
song like your song there's just
something bad happens to you too
regularly so I just started like messing
with the fan with his fans I'm just like
you know that song was about the time I
was really down and it was about that
time I soft lifted the ham and stuck it
down my pants and walked out the store
so thank you for supporting my music
thank you apparently and he's like I
think it was apparently like a
superstore billboard in Berlin it's like
I've seen the Billboard I was like okay
support I I see yeah I see a podcast
yeah this should be a path across I'll
do it do it you're hilarious
you've already done it you just didn't
undo it I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this